at their 2008 that was though is
probably too tough you know one of the
toughest calls I've had to make I know
nothing about technology I know nothing
but marketing I know nothing about
illegal all the stuff I do you know all
I know about people it is my intention
to live to the highest calling and be
pressed to the mark of the highest
calling that I have come to do
corns mother should make you money by
cheating people wanna be happy
build a life not just the business
I believe life ball
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believed life and learn some of the best
lessons from billionaire entrepreneurs
enjoy okay let's kick off with lesson
number one take risks with Elon Musk
2008 in particular was was resolved oh
because we had the third launch failure
in a row about Falcon one vehicle at
SpaceX and we the Tesla financing round
that we were raising fell apart because
the economy is going to tailspin it was
pretty hard to raise money for a
start-up car company you know late 2008
when GM and Chrysler a busy going
bankrupt that that was that was tough
and then Solar City had to deal with
Morgan Stanley and William Stanley had
to renege on the deal because they
themselves for any out of money
sold looked like old tree companies week
and I and I was also going through a
divorce so that was definitely a low
point you're going through a divorce
which like some to borrow your douchebag
bloggers are writing about to make even
worse right yes that's true in addition
to to a less stuff happening I was
getting dumped on massively in the press
right yeah you're know it looks like all
three companies yeah are gonna get file
I mean why do you keep going with all
three like I feel like even a lot of
great entrepreneurs in that situation
would have been like I've already sunk
up everything I have in these companies
and I got a pink one but you didn't I
mean you kept doing all three why yeah
that was that was a very tough call at
the end of 2008 that was though it's
probably too tough you know one of the
toughest calls I've had to make because
I could either reserve capital for one
company or the other I mean before Solar
City didn't need a ton of capitals they
were they were okay we're between
SpaceX and and an Tesla
you know it's sort of like like you've
got two kids and what do you do do you
spend all your money is to maximize
probably to successful of one or two use
you try to keep both laugh of course
Network lesson number two lean into your
dreams with Oprah Winfrey so it is my
intention my intention to fulfill the
dream of the creator it is my intention
to live to the highest calling and be
pressed to the mark of the highest
calling that I have come to do and when
you can ask the Creator ask that which
made you you what is your dream for me I
guarantee you instead of you trying to
define the dream what is your dream for
me if you're able to lean into the dream
that the universe and all the forces of
light and love and power and grace by
all the names that we call God has for
you nobody can touch you nobody can
touch you lesson number three think
ahead with Jeff Bezos I always tell
people sometimes I get you know we'll
have a good quarterly conference call or
something and and Wall Street will like
our quarterly results and I'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and I
say thank you but what I'm really
thinking is that quarter was baked three
years ago i right now I'm working on a
quarter that's going to reveal itself in
2021 sometime and that's what you need
to be doing you need to be out sort of
you know two or three years in advance
and if you are and then why do I need to
make a hundred decisions today if I make
like three good decisions a day that's
enough and they should just be as high
quality as I can make them also if you
want to have more confidence check out
my 254 series they're free the links to
join on the description below before we
are able to get the road through out
that then they would say well you
couldn't possibly make that car work
your number one job is to become more of
yourself it's really good to be
idealistic but be prepared to be
misunderstood lesson number four be
ethical with Warren Buffett both of us
know that we've done better by having
ethics Oren's not interested in making
money by cheating people
warns opinions of Wall Street investment
bankers would not endear him to their
mothers he fields it there for the most
part not out for their clients there out
for their own business interests in the
late 1960s there were just a flood of
accounting shenanigans and mergers built
upon false accounting and misleading
people it was a time when a lot of
charlatans were prevailing in Wall
Street and were being applauded by Wall
Street and I understood what the game
was about but I didn't want to play in
it so I closed down the partnership at
the end of 1969 and I took on the title
of chairman for the Berkshire Hathaway
lesson number five make others happy
with Jack Ma I know nothing about
technology I know nothing but marketing
I know nothing about illegal all the
stuff I do you know I don't know about
people I know people I was trained to be
a teacher as a teacher you want your
students better than you are you want
you've got your best product is just
students you want this student to be a
lawyer that's to become a banker that's
to be the entrepreneur that is a is a is
a is a mayor you Ramon don't want this
bankrupt that in the jail that is in
trouble so you always want people better
and then you have to listen to them you
want to see their name and then make the
all the things to making sure that you
can empower them you can make them keep
teamwork you can then collaborate so
this is how we do and I find the more
you care by a team the team will care
about you and the team will care about
their customers so I talk to all of my
people early days
don't make me happy don't love me make
your customer happy make your customer
love you and I will love you any minute
that is very simple so everything we do
as its founder make a custom happy get
your team make a team happy and you will
be happy
listen number six be patient with Bill
Gates and so I get to when I you know
say okay we're gonna build a
TB drug team we're gonna build the TB
vaccine team we're gonna build them up
you know kill all the mosquitoes in the
world gene drive CRISPR team I get to in
terms of how we fund that organize it
how many locations do we wait till they
have this result before we scale it up I
get to use the same or 80% the same type
of thinking that I exercised in terms of
okay let's go do Windows let's go do
Excel so it's backing engineers it's
getting a sense of the team you know
what needs to be added to that team or
the IQs on the team adding up as opposed
to subtracting from each other and it's
very comfortable because the the most
intense period of Microsoft was where
these teams were about size 30 and for
our diseases
you know typhoid rotavirus there's a lot
of diseases that hopefully you'll never
hear up again most of which don't exist
here in the US but so it is very very
similar
it takes a decade generally from start
to finish the AIDS vaccine actually
we're on year 14 and it'll probably be
another eight to ten years before that
one is completely done so some take as
long as as twenty years because there's
many dead ends and you have kind of a
portfolio of approaches but yes I feel
like my working with governments hiring
smart people managing teams it did
prepare me well for this very
operational organization that's a lot
like a business except that we're our
profit is lives saved as opposed to a
monetary measure and lesson number seven
the last told me for a very special
bonus clip is empower people with Mark
Zuckerberg take me inside Mark
Zuckerberg head to like the moment that
you decided you needed to change
Facebook's core mission it was there an
event that happened or was there just a
moment that you said we got to change
something
well for most of the last 10 years this
idea that the world should be more
connected was not very controversial
right and now I think they're starting
to be some people who question whether
that is good
so just been this evolution where for me
and for a lot of the people I work with
at Facebook you know we feel like giving
people a voice is a really important
thing to do but it's not enough to just
give people a voice you also have to you
know help build common ground right so
that way people can can move forward
together and and aren't just you know
sharing a lot of different opinions but
you actually have to help reconcile that
so that way people can can come together
as well and you know that's a lot of the
responsibility that we feel now and and
the mission that we want to take on for
the next ten years of the company you
keep hearing we've never been more
divided you've never been more polarized
was it the political climate that led to
kind of this awakening I think it's
really this feeling that simply
connecting the world is not enough by
itself that you also have to work and do
proactive work to help bring people
closer together right so you need to
give people a voice so we can get a
diversity of opinions out there but you
also need to do work to help build
enough common ground so that way we can
make progress as a society together
right you want to help people stay
connected with the people they already
know and care about but you also want to
make it so that people get access to new
people and new perspectives too so we're
gonna keep on doing everything that we
were doing before to connect friends and
family and and to help people share but
now we also want to help people build
communities all right and in other ways
that they can connect them and help
people bond and come together and spread
tolerance and a lot of the values that I
think we all want to see in the world
now I've got a special bonus cap from
Mark Cuban on how to be great at selling
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go
question number one how can you better
lean into your dreams this week number
two how can you make someone else happy
today and number three what's the risk
that you just need to
and if you made it this far new video
you're still watching and you commit you
promise to take action after watching
this video I want to celebrate you give
me a hashtag believed out in the
comments as well if you come up with an
idea where you say I can make dollar
bills for 50 Cent's would you go out and
raise money or would you just go out and
sell it you just go out and do it you
know and that's what you have to do and
look we all go through that fear factor
of do I quit my job do I can I do this
can I can I do this and what happens
next the one thing I know with a hundred
percent certainty and what I would tell
myself is if I can sell and become a
better and better salesperson and be
great at selling I'm always going to be
successful whether I'm working for
myself or at the company that I started
just didn't work I'll give you an
example out of Indiana before I went
down to Dallas I needed to start
something and I decided that everybody
drank milk and I found this product
powdered milk that was cheaper and
everybody needed to save money and I was
going to go out there and sell it
because it was cheaper now it didn't
taste quite as good and so what I've but
I went out there to try to sell it
failed miserably but I learned how to
make the sales effort even when things
weren't going right I learned that the
rejection was every no got me closer to
a yes that not every product was perfect
but I could take those same skills even
in failure and translate them so that
what I learned selling garbage bags
door-to-door what I learned from selling
powdered milk that was awful what I
learned from selling local area networks
at micro solutions all those things
accumulated and I got better at selling
so I always knew you know people always
say to me if you lost everything what
would you do I can sell
I can sell when it's not about selling
ice to Eskimos it's not about you know
convincing people to do this selling is
always about helping
selling is always about understanding
the person you're talking to and what
their needs are and if someone can help
me make my life easier
yeah people you know now with employees
people always say well like what's the
definition of a great employee someone
who can reduce the stress of those
around them and it's the same thing
what's the definition of a great
salesperson someone who can reduce the
stress of their salespeople and if in
looking at your company and looking at
your life and looking at your goals if
you're able to go out there and
recognize that whether it works or
doesn't work you're putting yourself in
a position where you're helping somebody
not convincing somebody but and you're
reducing their stress you're gonna
you're gonna be okay it's gonna work out
and you know that's the confidence I've
built in myself that wasn't necessarily
always there but I learned that if I try
to help if I reduce people's stress good
things can happen
if you want to see some more amazing
lessons from billionaires check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
have you ever met a person who was a
great reader when they were young who
was not successful the way I tend to
view problems this is from it from a
physics standpoint